that goes amigo went astray if you
enjoyed the live-action remake of
Disney's Beauty and the Beast then
you're going to love the next few years
Disney is currently planning 19 more
remakes of their Animated Classics the
remake of Mulan will be released in
November of 2018 the film is being held
by Niki Caro who will be only the second
woman in Disney history to direct a film
with a budget over 100 million dollars
The Lion King will be directed by Jon
Favreau who previously directed the
successful remake of The Jungle Book Tim
Burton who brought Disney's live-action
adaptation of Alice in Wonderland to
life has signed on to reimagine the
classic film Dumbo
the sword in the stone is being written
by Bryan cogman who has written multiple
episodes of Game of Thrones there have
been several Prince Charming's
throughout Disney history and apparently
this movie will offer a comedic glimpse
into the archetype itself the genie from
Aladdin is getting a prequel that for
now is just called genies meanwhile
Aladdin is getting remade by director
Guy Ritchie who has previously made very
undies like snatch and Lock Stock and
Two Smoking Barrels Emma Stone coming
hot off her Oscar win for lala land
we'll play the infamous Cruella Deville
in an origin story about the villain
congratulations that was wet I think I
feel like I said negative stuff about it
before the live-action adaptation of
Winnie the Pooh will apparently focus on
an adult Christopher Robin returning to
the Hundred Acre Wood to meet up with
his childhood companion while Disney is
planning a remake of The Little Mermaid
the studio will have to compete with
Universal Pictures who are also planning
their own live-action version there has
been a glut of peterpan remakes in
recent years but that's not slowing down
Disney from adapting a live-action
version of their animated classic the
studio is also reportedly creating a
spin-off about Tinkerbell starring Reese
Witherspoon the 1996 claymation version
of James and the Giant Peach based on
the raw doll book is rumoured to be
getting a new adaptation as
Pinocchio is reportedly getting a
live-action version that will be very
loosely based on the original animated
film after the box-office success of the
Jungle Book and Maleficent both films
currently have sequels in the works
probably the strangest potential remake
is one reportedly about Chernabog a
demon creature that appeared once in an
11 minute segment in the film Fantasia
apparently it will be similar to
Maleficent as it tries to humanize its
villain
finally there's Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs Disney's original animated film
this too is getting a remake with new
music from the guys who wrote the lyrics
for lala land
Disney is also planning a spin-off
called rose-red which will focus on Snow
White sister as she attempts to rescue
Snow White after she eats the poison
that are you excited for all these
live-action remakes
are there any not here that you wish
Disney would do let us know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe